thank you the academy for this honor of
honors Quentin Jerome Tarantino you are
original you are one of a kind Leo I'll
write on your coattails any day man
The View's fantastic
and to the rest of the cast and crew uh
big bad Bob Richardson
um
Robert Garcia Richie my man Mike Moe hey
you know I also want to say you know why
we're doing all this I think it's time
we we give a little love to our stunt
coordinators and our stunt
Cruz
I'm a big gobsmacked I'm not I'm not one
to look back but this has made me do so
and I think of my folks taking me to the
drive-in to see Butch and Sundance and
loading up my car and moving out here
and
Gina and Ridley give me my first shot to
all the wonderful people I've met along
the way
to stand here now
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I think
that's the truth
[Applause]